now let's let's talk about the war on
drugs the war on drugs yeah this is a
very very important one for all of you I
know I think this is in this is huge
while a question to all of you listening
should Trump pardon every federal inmate
convicted on nonviolent marijuana
related charges
that's my question for you seventh out
seven seventy six thousand eight hundred
and twenty six votes on this poll here
seventy six thousand votes 53.9 so my
fifty four percent said yes eight point
four said no twenty seven point two said
not every but some ten point five
abstained just wanted to see the results
so that's over eighty percent of seventy
six thousand people that think yes we
should we should do that even even if
even though a little bit of them are
going you know maybe you know maybe not
all but a lot of really good points were
brought up in this so stick sex and
hammer with the top slot says wokes
Meade ever ever DeRay all right nice six
more feet all right Jack Murphy of
democratic deplorable Fame here at the
book no what if Trump legalized weed and
released all nonviolent weed offenders
everyone's saying yes the Chet is
lighting up yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes dude Trump I agree I think you
should he says that's leader leadership
without capitulation it's the moral high
ground and on message for Trump release
the black men who are shamefully
imprisoned over possessing a plant
leadership yes I love it a plant that
was legal for the longest time it's an
excuse and a lot of ways to even lock
people up and jam them up yeah that is
exactly what I was gonna get to it is an
excuse to lock people up and make make
money it's like a money income situation
for these small towns big town's cities
all of them look at all these yeses man
this is great
yeah yeah knows some knows I I saw one
no so far but check us out we got some
good points that were brought up in this
right vanilla Thrilla says what about
those with a history of violent crime
that just happened to get nailed and
convicted for weed
I answered not all but some for what
it's worth so wait wait wait did they
get convicted of a vile
crime do their time and get let out
exactly and then they got caught with
with some weed on them exactly so they
did their time what so so what we're
gonna let go of that that if you if you
mess up do your time and get out that
you did your time exactly what what what
does that have to do with it it's a good
point though it's a good question yeah
sure
I mean it's so violent but but you said
nonviolent crime and so the question is
what about people with a violent history
okay we just happen to be caught on this
one crime my response is if you can't
prove someone committed the other crime
it's irrelevant to me if somebody now
Cassandra Cassandra Fairbanks chimed in
with actually a really good point okay
this is tricky because a lot of them are
on our other a lot a lot of them are
other more serious crimes but pleaded
down that's a really good point so it
was recorded in the books as a non
violent crime yep right but the actual
situation was could have been violent or
so like let's say somebody had a gun and
was you know a drug they were slinging
drugs and had a gun and then they ran
for it and they were armed and then like
you know stole someone's car or
something well I guess I guess it's a
violence yeah that's right no no but
Grand Theft Auto hold on hold on and
then they say something like the cops
say okay you stole the car you know at
gunpoint mm-hmm but if you tell us where
you got the weed we'll drop you down to
possession and distribution and then
they go deal and now they're on the
books as just possession and
distribution and then they get released
because of that and they're actually
violent offenders but they helped bring
down they snitched basically it's just
an issue of there's a lot of there's a
lot of cases where like somebody may
have been you know selling drugs yeah
and then Rob's a drug dealer and then
the cops are like we're gonna get them
on the drug charges it's it's gonna be
difficult to prove because the other the
other the victims are other criminals
who won't plead down to it however I
still lean towards I don't like the idea
of a justice system that plays the game
of the trial tax dude that is no what is
that
so when they offer you lighter sentence
sentences to just give up the problem
with that is because I've had it used
against me before so i when i was III
got a I got false speeding ticket
cop pulled me over I wasn't speeding
gave me a ticket long story short I
didn't know anything about how the law
worked I was - what I was like 19 or so
and my sister paid the ticket for me and
as soon as it happened it immediately
suspended my license I received nothing
in the mail had no idea even happened I
take it was paid I had my license I was
fine right then I'm driving and I get
pulled over and I get told I'm driving
on a suspended license and that now I'm
under arrest they did something in
Illinois called an I bond where they
immediately arrest me and then released
me on the spot
gave me my court date when I went to
court I was told that if I plead guilty
I can pay a fine of like 125 bucks and
get court supervision but if I try to
actually go to trial they would fight
for a year in jail Wow a full year
that's the trial tax they said hey we're
gonna throw the book at you because you
haven't accepted responsibility and so
when I was talking to the prosecutor the
DA I was just completely honest and I
said can I just tell you what happened
he goes sure what happened and I said I
I received a ticket
it was bunk but I was visiting my sister
on a military base at Fort Carson
Colorado and I was taught given the
option to just pay the fine so I did
when I was driving back I didn't receive
any notice that my license is suspended
and I was coming home from visiting my
sister call my husband my brother-in-law
was overseas and then when I was coming
back I got pulled over and he goes hmm
so you confessed to me that you were
driving on a suspended license yeah
that's a year in jail $2,500 fine if you
plead guilty though I'll go easy on you
and I was like what and then when I went
up to the judge the judge was like he's
like he's like I understand you'll be
pleading guilty and I was like yes your
honor and then he asked me these
questions and one of them was have you
been coerced in any way to give this
plea to the court I said yes your honor
and he went what and I was like yes your
honor
and he goes someone coerced you to plead
guilty and I went yeah yes I was like I
didn't do anything wrong the guy told me
who's gonna put me in jail for a year
and the judge goes get a lawyer and come
back and then the lawyer told Matt I
call the lawyer I had to pay off Palace
money and he said just plead guilty it's
the only thing you can do
Wow and the ticket I got on the whole
thing was bunk and the whole thing was
BS I never and they talked they said
ignorant of the law is no excuse for
breaking it so it's it's what oh right
right right yeah so anyway anyway well I
wanna I wanna look at this we gotta give
it up to Elon
so when when Ilan must says this is
probably gonna get me into trouble
but I feel like I have to send tweets
that out I don't know how I don't know
how long it was between the two tweets
but then he goes selling weed literally
went from a major felony to essential
businesses it's been open during the
pandemic in much of America and yet many
people are still in prison it doesn't
make sense does it
I agree it isn't right look at all look
at this he's absolutely right this is
the this is the opposite of a ratio it
was it was an essential business people
people can't even run their own
businesses and yet weed pharmacies are
open you know legal places well hold on
hold on
this Elon Musk tweet is the opposite of
a ratio look at it it's got 176 thousand
retweets and 13,000 responses that is a
10 to 1 positive ratio of people being
like here here I'll tell you what if
Trump I really believe if Trump you know
it might happen though well Trump's not
gonna give it all up right away know if
he came out right now and said I'm just
gonna do it why would anyone have an
incentive to vote that's right that's
one of his uh his vote for me and I'm
gonna fight for this he's gonna it's
gonna be like a month out and he's gonna
be like I sat down with some top
advisors a criminal reform and we've
decided to do an executive order
releasing the overall majority of
inmates on nonviolent drug related
offenses yep he needs to do it he does I
gotta say man I'm a big fan of the
Portugal method I am very libertarian on
this issue and I don't mean big el like
I'm lefty libertarian yeah
legalize them all yeah I agree regulate
control you help people
yes you know it's like if somebody wants
if somebody wants to do a drug where
they're addicted let them go somewhere
to get cheap effective and clean at
treatment yeah that's like them better
their lot that's a government program I
can get behind yep helping someone why
are you why are you hooked on on this
why do you feel you need this in your
life not even not even government though
like her private think of it this way
yeah open it up so I I I was uh there's
a story that I read about an 18 year old
kid who went to college okay he got
drunk he passed out his friend said he
looks really bad just put him on the
ouch and lamb on his side he died he had
alcohol poisoning and the reason nobody
called 9-1-1 was because there wasn't
they were like well we'll all get in
trouble for underage drinking
he'll be fine just don't do anything and
he died of alcohol poisoning yep I said
and so a lot of that there been people
trying to campaign to reduce the
drinking age back to 18 because you have
people who are literally adults living
on their own who can't drink beer like
everyone else but they will and then
they have no chance to go to the
hospital out of fear of breaking the law
so I look at drugs that way let's say
somebody's doing a hard drug and right
now it's illegal what do they do they go
to that they go to a scummy back-alley
shack and they start putting in their
toes to hide it now it's dirty now
there's diseases now they're getting
sick and then they OD someone someone
from my neighborhood that I a friend of
mine od'd a long time ago
and I dude I can tell you a really
creepy story man I'm gonna tell you a
really creepy story
you wanna hear really creepy story well
now you got to tell me so let me just
wrap up this one thought and I'll tell
you how crazy this story is but uh if if
we had even private facilities that
controlled the use of a certain of any
drug then you have someone come in
they're not gonna OD because you've
measured you've calculated and you got
someone watching and making sure they're
doing all right and then guess what you
can tax it you can control it when you
when you ban things you lose control of
it the same thing is true for the speech
on these platforms true like this where
I've said when they banned sargon of
akkad from patreon I'm like patreon
could have actually went to him and said
promise us you won't say this word again
you're good and he would've been like
you got it no problem instead they were
like we're banning you outright with no
recourse so what happens he has no
incentive to do to do any better that
you know or I'd do anything that they
would consider to be better he just
carries on like normal in fact it
actually it pushes people into the
darkness because they have nowhere else
to go so anyway that's my picture
tonight I want to tell you a crazy story
oh do tell but this is just a weird
listen man so at this point it may be
it's from my neighborhood from
decade-plus ago but you know 15 years
ago whatever you mean Chicago Chicago
South Side Chicago and this is the story
as it was told to me and I think just to
be fair they may have embellished
because they wanted the story to be true
okay but there was one dude in my
neighborhood
was oh he was always working you worked
at a fast-food restaurant and he always
worked late shifts just always worked
people would hit him up hey can you come
over now I'm working and be like you
sure man we're gonna go out and we're
apart he's like nah I'm working till
like 1:00 in the morning cuz he worked
at a Taco Bell okay so one day for no
reason he goes to his boss and he says
I'm not feeling good I feel I just I
gotta go home man I'm not feeling good
and the boss was like you sure like you
always work extra shifts you always pick
up late hours hey man look if you know
whenever it whenever I've needed your
help
you've always picked up shifts so if you
need to take some time off right now for
whatever reason just go really really
strange in the middle of his shift he
just said I gotta leave I don't feel
good he didn't go home he started
walking down Archer Avenue and he walked
two miles to another one of our friend's
house and he doesn't know why he doesn't
know why he took off work and he showed
up and would be find two of our friends
od'd in the car and then he called 9-1-1
and they saved him and they said if you
didn't get here by the time you did
these guys would be dead what and then
one of our friends was like bro weren't
you working tonight and he was like yeah
and they were like why'd you leave work
I don't know man Wow why did you you
walked out of work you never do that and
he was freaking out and he was like bro
I don't know I just I just felt like I
had to come here dude yeah and then what
did he find
oh now I'll tell you what it's a crazy
story so I kind of like yeah yeah yeah
you know maybe it's just like I don't
know right but I think a lot of people
want to believe that there was some kind
of divine intervention that saved those
guys lives I think humans have have
abilities that they have yet to tap
because we're we're just so comfortable
in our lives right now we have no reason
to be pushed to use these abilities not
not I don't know what it would be but
you know it's intuition you know if you
will your instincts there's a you're
good you know I've had so many instances
where I didn't follow my gut and I'm
like man maybe it maybe I should stop
skateboarding right now
then you get hurt and then boom I I get
hit by a car and fracture my cheekbone
that happened straight up Wow I have the
stinks and I was like man I should I
should probably take it easy chill for a
little bit but no boom get hit by a cab
like laugh about it later here's the
piers the crazy thing depending on who
you talk to about that story mm-hmm
you'll get different responses obviously
when I would talk to my religious
friends they'd be like bro that's a
guardian angel right there that's God
that's that's that's you know that's the
Lord saving the lives invoking that man
to do something he wouldn't normally do
to be the miracle yeah my hippie friends
are like bro dude premonition he could
see it quantum entanglement and it's
right just like and I'm like yeah or
like it's just it happens sometimes it
rains you know what I mean yeah it's
still a crazy story I love that story
and I'm like a good story it really
could just be embellished cuz everybody
loves a good story but sure I can tell
you the bulk of it is true they were
found they got pulled out he likes
sprayed him with a hose then like that
they got narcan and they were like these
guys would have been dead man Wow if you
didn't just show up randomly and some
people took it to a dark place and Amit
was like nah they hit him up and they
were like we're gonna score you want to
come by and I'm like they were Oh deed
like they were in the car already yeah
they weren't waiting for him like I
don't buy it
and this dude worked all the time he
never took off work like what why why
yeah why would you assume that he wanted
to gain on it when he was the one who
never left work I'm not saying the guy
was a good dude or anything yeah but he
worked at a fast food restaurant and he
always worked late
the one time wow that's crazy right yeah
yeah who knows sometimes we win the
lottery you know what I mean true but I
think a lot of people like stories like
that they want to believe them because
it's it gives you something to there's
something bigger than you
maybe there's a purpose you know maybe
there's something we can't we can't see
you call it abilities got intuition or
something some people might think it's
it's divine or some kind of you know
hidden force guiding us and keeping us
safe or or a mix of both yeah yeah I
mean I don't know what happens after I
die but I'll tell you what when I die
I'll know that's right
or you won't because the concept of
knowing is in your human body man that's
exactly true
do you remember what was like before you
were born no exact question right
because I was like why yeah
I don't know what happened I don't know
what was going on before I was born
either and for all I know it's just
gonna be like that after I die but why
do you hate that no it's it goes counter
to everything that I was raised with
well you know what I don't know but I do
know one thing that is absolutely true I
am alive right now yeah Here I am I'm
here speaking to you I'm alive I'm so
happy to be alive I love this planet I
love the Sun praise the Sun a ball
energy keeping that grass growing and
that it's coming and boom we eat various
forms of it we are all just comprised of
various amalgamations of random solar
energy this is why I like stoicism
because their focus is on every single
second you live in the moment you don't
worry about the future
you don't fret about the past and you'll
waste time on regrets boom you spent
every moment in the moment
and that's the way to do it I'm like
then I don't really see a better way to
do it than that so I think we man you
know I love having conversations about
time reality purpose wasn't that what
our show was supposed to be about no but
it was partly I know we're doing it
right now and you mean we're on the show
talking about and I'm so happy
you know when it comes to man let me
tell you something let me tell you some
this this segment we're doing right now
is about pot oh yeah we totally just had
a STONER Congress will do say your
you're the bigger stoner than me totally
true which is pretty hilarious true come
on really
I don't smoke wait hold on I mean
literally what do you think about that I
don't smoke I don't drink no no drugs
yeah that stuff yeah that's true yeah I
don't I you know to go back to that
story because I didn't mention maybe it
was embellished when I when I you know I
think it happened but I think people are
looking deeper into it because they want
to have some meaning or they won't have
you know they want to believe yeah they
want to believe that everything's gonna
be okay you know people are scared of
dying for obvious reasons like
everything is alive
fans we got it we got to cherish that
yeah we got to stop being afraid of
things thicker skin confidence you only
get one life man so I'll say it one more
time
cancel participation trophies seriously
this this a big reason that's part of it
we're teaching our kids that you don't
have to fight to survive we have fought
to survive for so long that's what's
humans do that's why we took over this
planet yeah man
could you imagine living in a world
create where these people take over and
life is no there's no journey anymore
that's I mean that's happening everybody
thinks that you know they say things
like the ends justify the means but it's
not true because you never meet the end
no matter where you are in life you're
always like you're always looking off in
the distance you're chasing the dragon
man yeah so what what world would they
create where everyone sits around in a
circle and a great jumpsuit with shaved
heads and just does nothing exists eats
their green cube of protein mass what's
that movie equilibrium yeah no emotions
no emotions mm-hmm just great NPCs
living yeah for what that's what it's
all about man they're banning art thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you